there are many varieties of Spanish
spoken throughout the world which all
share the same Common Core but also have
some of their own features two of the
varieties that are often said to be the
most unique or different from others are
Chilean Spanish and Argentinian Spanish
spoken in the southern cone of South
America I've already covered Chilean
Spanish in a video I made last year so
in today's video we're talking about
Argentinian Spanish well to be precise
the type of Spanish I'll be focusing on
is Rio platensei Spanish which is spoken
in much of Argentina including Buenos
Aires as well as a neighboring Uruguay
that name comes from Rio de La Plata the
name of the area's major Estuary and its
Basin it literally means River of silver
the original inhabitants of the area
were indigenous people who spoke
languages such as kichua juarany and
mapuche so after Spanish settlers began
arriving in the 16th century the variety
of Spanish that developed there was
influenced by those languages some
indigenous words are still used in Rio
platense for example the word Tambo
which refers to a dairy farm this word
comes from quechua the word shusho which
means weed also comes from quechua this
word meaning a type of rodent
this word comes from the mapuche
language it's used in Argentina Uruguay
and Chile but in Argentina it also has
the meaning of a skinny unathletic
person the word meaning dude or guy
comes from the word charabon which is a
varani origin It Means A young Ria a
type of bird
and there are numerous other words of
indigenous origin some of them appearing
mainly in Rio platense and others
appearing in several other varieties of
Latin American Spanish as well
we'll talk more about the historical
influences on Rio platense in a minute
but first I'd like to tell you a little
bit more about our sponsor baselang
baselang is an online school where you
can take unlimited one-on-one Spanish
lessons whenever you want in almost any
time of the day for one fixed monthly
membership fee how is that possible well
the basic idea is that they have lots of
teachers and a free booking system so
you can schedule lessons with the
teachers that are available at the times
that are convenient for you so you don't
have a fixed schedule with the same
teacher every time but if you prefer a
certain teacher you can schedule lessons
with them again you can always choose
between a prepared lesson and a
conversational lesson I think the main
benefit lies in the conversational
lessons because you can study the
rudiments of a language by yourself the
real learning comes when you apply those
Basics while speaking your target
language so you can get unlimited
speaking practice for one fixed monthly
fee how much is it it's a hundred and
forty nine dollars per month that may
sound expensive to some of you but the
per lesson cost is very low if you take
lots of lessons if you're excited to
improve your Spanish rapidly and you
take Five Lessons a week that's 7 45 per
lesson 10 lessons a week less than 375
per lesson the prices are incredible if
you take lots of lessons and if you
don't well then you're not taking full
advantage of a great opportunity if
you'd like to try it out and see if
you're motivated enough to take
advantage of that system you can try it
for one week for just one dollar use my
link in the description along with my
coupon code langfocus for a special
discount if you stay past the first week
and now back to the history of Spanish
and Rio de La Plata the Spanish
Incorporated this area into the vice
royalty of Peru then later the vice
royalty of Rio De La Plata but in the
19th century the vice royalty broke up
into a number of independent countries
including Argentina and Uruguay towards
the end of that Century large-scale
migration from Europe began in
particular from Northern Italy and from
Southern Italy in the first half of the
20th century these immigrants had a
significant impact on the way Spanish is
spoken in Argentina and Uruguay it's
often said that Rio platense Spanish was
influenced by Italian but it's more
accurate to say that it was influenced
by languages of Italy because immigrants
arrived from various parts of the
country speaking their own Regional
languages like Lombard a language of
Northern Italy and the politano a
language of southern Italy the influence
of the languages of Italy remains in the
intonation of Rio platense Spanish which
some describe as sing-songi not a very
technical description I know rather than
trying to describe it let's just listen
to an example first we'll hear a sample
of a speaker from Spain then a sample of
a speaker from Argentina
architecture
is
Italian influence is also evident in Rio
platense slang called Lun fardordo a
name which comes from Lombardo meaning
from the Lombard region of Italy where
most of the first wave of Italian
immigrants came from it's said that Lun
fardordo was first developed as a way of
speaking among prison inmates so that
the guards wouldn't understand them but
then spread more generally amongst the
lower socioeconomic classes and
eventually some of it entered the
informal speech of all social classes
here are some common lymphadero words
that are a part of Rio platense speech
this is a greeting meaning something
like hey or what's up and can be used to
grab someone's attention from what I
understand it's most commonly used in
Buenos Aires but also elsewhere
throughout the region its etymology is
uncertain
ciao is the most common way to say bye
rather than or adios probably because of
Italian influence though it's used in
some other varieties of Spanish as well
this means okay as opposed to Vale or in
Mexico Saleh Mina this is a word for a
woman you don't know which might come
from Italian femina which means female
or from the Lombard word Mina which
means a busty woman from what I
understand it's not very polite but it's
also not overtly insulting maybe it's
something like chick in English a word I
used to hear a lot when I was a kid
like Chico and Chica in general Spanish
meaning guy or gal in English these come
from Italian pivello which means novice
or rookie from the Italian word for face
meaning money I'm not sure about the
origin of this one some Spanish language
sources say it comes from a Germanic
word wita perhaps from Gothic but I'm
not sure how that would have entered Rio
platense la the word for work this comes
from Italian lavoro
one element of lymphadodo is that the
syllables of words are sometimes
playfully reversed similar to French
verlon this is called vesere a reversal
of Reves which means reverse for example
meaning heat from Spanish
notice that not all Loom photo the slang
comes from languages of Italy meaning
coffee this comes from Spanish cafe or
Italian Cafe
meaning woman from Spanish
sometimes it's not exactly a reversal of
the syllables but the syllables are
rearranged
outside from Spanish
inside from Spanish
excuse me from Spanish permiso now what
use would slang be without some crude
vocabulary
this means something like apple prick or
douche in other words a person who's not
very nice or who has terrible Behavior
originally this meant a person with big
testicles whether male or female
originally it was an insult but now it's
used like bro or dude and derived from
that there's the word
which is a verb meaning something like
to sit around or hang around of course
there's also real placente vocabulary
that isn't really slang to say good
morning Rio platense speakers say wendia
instead of Buenos Dias this is sometimes
true in other varieties of Spanish but
less commonly in general Spanish buenos
dias usually means good morning while
buendia means have a nice day
the word for refrigerator is as opposed
to free horrifico used in Spain and
refrigerator used in other parts of
Latin America the word for swimming pool
as well as sink is this comes from Pila
meaning wash basin plus the suffix ETA
which forms diminutives or other related
nouns the word for t-shirt is instead of
the word
this comes from the word Remo which
means paddle but can also be used
informally to mean an arm or a leg and a
t-shirt is a shirt that doesn't cover
your arms so some real potential
vocabulary isn't exclusive to Argentina
and Uruguay but is found in certain
other Latin American countries as well
the word for strawberry as opposed to
pressure in most varieties of Spanish
this word is used in the Rio platensei
of Argentina and Uruguay and some
related dialects in Paraguay Bolivia and
Chile it's a diminutive of the word
meaning fruit but hold on a second let's
hear that word again
why is there a Shu sound here in Rio
platensei the sound represented by LL is
pronounced rather than the typical
pronunciations
meaning Street Sounds like and there's
its vestre equivalent shika
Pollo meaning chicken sounds like bosho
she got to the office on time as in most
varieties of Spanish the letter y is
pronounced the same as the Double L the
word for I sure
my name is Paul
similar to numerous other varieties of
Spanish in Rio platensei Spanish there's
a tendency to aspirate sounds resulting
in a pronunciation like a h sound like H
in English
when spoken in a sentence gusta sounds
more like and antes sounds more like
ante in Rio platense this mainly happens
when s appears before other consonants
and in this case here the consonant is
in the following word for some speakers
the aspiration doesn't happen at the end
of a word only before a consonant within
the word
a couple more examples
I like speaking Spanish
fish before a vowel the S sound is
generally fully pronounced meaning house
not kaha but there are some dialects in
Northern Argentina where those are
aspirated too these dialects are not
strictly real Placentia dialects though
Rio platense Spanish is Spanish and its
grammar is almost entirely the same as
the Spanish of Spain and other varieties
but it's noteworthy for its use of bosel
meaning that the informal second person
singular pronoun too is replaced by boss
even in media and formal contexts evils
and you rather than itu boss is also
used as the object of a preposition like
in this sentence meaning this is for you
rather than
and unlike in some varieties of Spanish
with boseo Rio platensei uses separate
different conjugations for Boss Learners
of Spanish who visit Argentina or
Uruguay are often caught off guard when
they hear bosos instead of where are you
from
rather than
of course Spanish is pro drop so here
the pronouns are implied and the only
indication of boseo is in the verb forms
both of them are conjugations of ser one
of the two verbs meaning to be Ser is an
irregular verb but what about regular
verbs to get the regular present tense
both conjugations you remove the final R
from the infinitive form and add an s in
its place the stress falls on the final
syllable so the present tense both
conjugation of bintan is pensas
what do you think about that compare
that to the tuteo sentence
to get the boss imperative form you
remove the final R from the infinitive
form and the stress falls on the final
syllable so the most imperative of
pensar is
think about it compare that to the tuteo
imperative sentence
here are a couple of last minute
additions based on recommendations from
a native speaker in Rio platensei the
word Alto or Alta which means hi is used
to say that something is really good
a really good match in standard Spanish
hits
another example of using a standard word
with a special meaning in Rio platense
is using Mal which means bad to say that
something's good
how was the movie
it was really good you can also say Mal
to agree with someone
it's really hot today isn't it
yes bro or bad bro
so what is it that makes Argentinian
Spanish different from the others well
it has different intonation a different
accent with some different consonant
sounds a minor grammatical difference
and some Regional vocabulary and slang
that sounds like almost any other
variety of Spanish I have to be honest
before I started looking into this video
I thought Rio platense would be much
more different from other varieties of
Spanish because people talk about it
like it's from Mars or something I'm
guessing that those people are probably
fixated on the pronunciation of Double L
and Y as Shu because at first it really
stands out but once you get used to that
it's no greater of a difference than the
th sound of Spain being pronounced as Su
in Latin America beyond that Rio
platensei has its own little bit of
spice but it's really not that different
from other forms of Spanish but hold on
a second a native speaker of Spanish
told me that he disagrees that Rio
platensei is actually kind of hard to
understand because of its Regional
vocabulary and slang so let me ask you
if you're a speaker of Rio platense
Spanish do speakers of other varieties
ever have trouble understanding you do
you have to adjust your speech and to
Learners of Spanish what's your
experience with Rio platensei do you
find it harder to understand than other
varieties
as always I'd like to say thank you to
the langfocus patreon supporters who
make it possible to bring you
educational content like this the people
whose names you see right here on the
screen are the top tier patreon
supporters so let's give them all a
round of applause if you're interested
in Spanish then check out my playlist of
videos about the Spanish language there
are videos about other varieties of
Spanish comparisons of Spanish with
other languages and even a video about a
spanish-based creole language check it
out